فعلا سننطلق من هذه التطورات المعلنه من
قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي وحينما نتحدث عما
اعلنه الجيش الاسرائيلي فاحن نتحدث
بالاساس عن المنطقه الشماليه هذه المنطقه
التي شهدت تحركا ل او اعلانا للجيش
الاسرائيلي بحب الفرقه 36 التي كانت تتحرك
بالاساس هنا في المناطق الشماليه وتحديدا
في منطقه بيت لاهيه وبيت حان
وايضا في في ايضا المناطق الغربيه من
مدينه غزه وحتى في الشجاعيه في ال 21 من
ديسمبر كان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن بان
الفرقه 36 التي كانت موجوده هنا في هذه
المنطقه قد اكملت ما سماه عمليه تفكيك
القدرات الاساسيه لحركه حماس في الشجاعيه
هذه الفرقه لاحقا انتقلت الى المناطقه
الوسطى وتحديدا جحر الديك ومنطقه البريج
لكن هذه التطورات في الشمال تاتي بينما
كان هناك قصف لمدينه غزه اليوم كان
مراسلنا تحدث عن ان هذا القصف قد تسبب في
استشهاد نحو
33 فلسطينيا في مدينه غزه كان هناك ايضا
قصف ل ايضا حي الزيتون مما يعني بانه مع
هذه الانسحابات او هذا اعاده تموضع القوات
الاسرائيليه لازال عمليه زالت استهداف
الشمال قائما بالانتقال الى المنطقه
الوسطى وتحريض في مخيم البريج كنا تحدثنا
سابقا عن عمليه استهداف لهذه المنطقه كان
هناك قصف مكثف للمناطق الوسطى ربما اشير
اليه على انه قد يكون للتغطيه على عمليات
الانسحاب المعلنه تحدث مراسلون ايضا عن
اشتباكات ضاريه
وبالاسحار الفلسطينيه وتحديدا كتائب
القسام والقوات الاسرائيليه في مخيم
البريش كان هناك ايضا هناك قصف بالقنابل
الفسفوريه لمخيم المغازي اذا المنطقه
الوسطى بدورها لازالت هدفا للقوات
الاسرائيليه مع العن بان ثلاثه فرق اعلن
الجيش بانها لازالت تعمل في قطاع غزه وهي
من بينها الفرقه 98 و99 والفرقه
162 مع العن بان الفرقه 99 حسب صحيفه
معريف هي المكله المنطقه الوسطى ربما نختم
بالحديث عن المنطقه ايضا الجنوبيه حيث كان
هناك ايضا اعلان للقسام عن استهداف اليات
عسكريه هنا في وسط مدينه قان يونس ولكن
كان ايضا اعلانها عن اشتباكات واستهداف
تحشد للقوات الاسرائيليه في اكثر من محور
سرايا القدس اعلنت الامر نفسها اذا الجبهه
الاخرى التي لا زالت من اسخن الجبهات هي
الجبهه الجنوبيه في خان يونس لعل ايمان
التطور الابرز هو ما هذه الانسحابات
المعلن عنها في الشم